pensemos en los escenarios donde yo
puedo tomar dinero prestado de ustedes
aquí estoy yo y aquí están ustedes en el
primer escenario tomé prestado de
ustedes una cantidad relativamente
pequeña de dinero voy a tomar prestado
100 dólares ustedes me van a prestar 100
dólares y después en una semana dentro
de una semana yo les voy a devolver esos
100 dólares a ustedes los voy a devolver
voy a pagar 100 dólares más algo de
interés y vamos a calcular el interés
con una base anual pero por supuesto
será menos del interés anual ya que yo
les voy a devolver el dinero en una
semana el otro escenario es que yo toma
prestado de ustedes durante más tiempo
vamos a ponerlo en rosa aquí tomó
prestado de nuevo 100 dólares pero en
lugar de pagarles dentro de una semana
les voy a pagar en dos años en dos años
les voy a devolver los 100 dólares
más cierto interés
lo que quiero que pensemos aquí es hay
una razón por la que debemos calcular el
interés con una base anual debo tener
una razón de interés diferente para el
tiempo de préstamo corto y para el
tiempo de préstamo largo ya que tenemos
la misma cantidad prestada la misma
legitimidad y todo eso y ustedes podrían
ser bueno mira en una semana hay menos
oportunidad de que algo catastrófico
ocurra hay más predictibilidad se tiene
un mejor sentido de lo que va a ocurrir
en el mundo dentro de una semana en
comparación de lo que puede ocurrir
dentro de dos años en dos años podemos
entrar en un ambiente super
inflacionario o me puede golpear un
camión o puedo perder mi trabajo hay
muchas más cosas que pueden ocurrir en
dos años en lo que puede ocurrir en una
semana y por eso ustedes pueden decir
que este préstamo de acá es más riesgoso
ya que siempre está la posibilidad de
que algo suceda y por eso si hago el
préstamo durante más tiempo es más
riesgoso por lo que con la base anual
voy a cargar más interés voy a cobrar un
mayor interés mayor interés con base
anual
con base anual
así que lo mejor en este escenario de
aquí ustedes dicen bueno ya que es una
semana te voy a cobrar un interés del 5%
un interés del 5% anual aunque el
interés que pague dentro de una semana
va a ser una fracción de este 5% y por
acá ya que hay más riesgo hay más
incertidumbre el interés que yo voy a
cobrar o que ustedes me van a cobrar a
mí será del 10 por ciento de interés
anual no siempre se da el caso de que
mientras mayor sea el periodo del
préstamo se debe tener un interés mayor
pero tiende a darse ese caso si el
interés es menor veremos en un vídeo
futuro que esto podría mostrar que algo
malo puede ocurrir con la economía que
podríamos tener un periodo de deflación
pero el punto de este vídeo es
mostrarles que dependiendo de qué tanto
tiempo alguien tome prestado dinero de
otra persona podrían cargar una mayor
cantidad de interés anual dependiendo
del riesgo percibido lo mismo sucede
cuando las personas les prestan a las
corporaciones o al gobierno federal
veremos en el siguiente vídeo cómo
funciona esto en la